one thing i probably should make clear
is that this idea of getting a two
percent management fee and then
participating in the profits at around
20 getting this 20 carried interest this
isn't unique to hedge funds this is
actually the same compensation structure
that you'll normally have at a venture
capital fund or a private equity fund
and just to be clear venture capital
really is a form of private equity but
normally when someone says private
equity they're not talking about venture
capital in particular in all of these
situations the managers will get roughly
two percent on the for managing the fund
it'll get twenty percent of the profits
the only difference really in terms of
how it's structured and a venture
capital or private equity fund will
still have kind of a limited partnership
for the actual fund and then they would
have a management company that gets the
management fees and the profits the only
difference is because a hedge fund
for the most part is probably going to
invest in public securities it could get
the money right from the get-go and put
that money to work because it tends to
invest in fairly liquid assets
so this is fairly liquid assets that
they can just go out and buy so a hedge
fund will normally just take as much
money as it needs to invest right from
the beginning a venture capital firm or
a private equity firm what they'll do is
they'll say look
i'm gonna raise a hundred million dollar
fund but i'm not gonna be able to just
go out the door tomorrow and invest a
hundred million dollars in the case of a
venture capital firm they're going to
have to look at business plans and
entrepreneurs and do their due diligence
same thing for a private equity firm
they're going to have to look for
companies that they might want to buy
private equity you're normally talking
about more mature companies that maybe
this firm things that they can buy and
turn around maybe more mature companies
that need some money to grow really fast
venture capital tends to be investing in
you know some guys in a business plan or
maybe you know these smaller kind of
more i guess you should call it more
risky companies
but in either of these situations they
won't just find them tomorrow so what
they do is they go to their investors
and they get their investors to commit
to commit a certain amount of money to
say commit a hundred million dollars and
they'll get the management fee they'll
get the management fee on what those
investors commit but they won't take the
money right then and there they'll take
the money as they need it they'll do
what's called a capital call to their
investors saying hey i just found a good
five million dollar investment i now
need your your this percentage of what
you committed to so that i can go out
and make the investment in the hedge
fund that's not the case all of it is up
front but it really is the same
compensation scheme and that's why if
you go to any fancy business school
you'll find um these are kind of the
careers uh that that that uh at least
the people who are interested in in uh
well i don't wanna i don't wanna give
them any kind of kind of characteristics
you know there's a bunch of reasons why
people would wanna go into these but but
these are definitely sought after
careers at a lot of fancy business
schools